hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
girls dark secrets five truths by the
truths i have a little bit of a lisp by
the fresh and fit
podcast which was the second most voted
for
thing i should react to in my pull so
far before i start do not forget to like
comment
and subscribe what do youtubers do like
hit that subscribe button please
please um i just figured like
i'm a girl right and
i don't think i have any dark secrets
but according to this podcast maybe i do
let's let's find out today we're going
to talk about
five dirty secrets that women don't want
you to know
hide your girlfriend because we're gonna
tell the truth on this one okay let's
get into it
[Music]
all right guys so we're gonna count this
down from five to one
number five you gotta understand this
fundamental truth okay
women are designed to survive i mean for
that matter
all humans are designed to survive but
women take it to another level
they look at men as an expendable
resource to get what they need not just
for them guys but also
for what their children okay and guys in
this case don't forget right
your mother loves you for you but women
love you for what you can do for them
so for the most part think about this
right whenever you meet a girl
what's the agenda is it to marry you
have sex
or purely motivation to get something
out of you keep that in mind
yeah guys the only woman that loves you
unconditionally is your mom is your mama
that's
it bro you know what i'm saying that's
why i mean that's true you can't
treat your wife or girlfriend like trash
it's it's conditional i'm peeing you
know a good boyfriend she says you're
handsome no matter how ugly you really
are how fat you are how broke you are
she's gonna always say you're handsome
okay
but other women are always going to be
extremely
pragmatic when they mate select and this
other thing you guys got to understand
girls are ruthless when it comes to who
they deal with
romantically they might sit here and
virtue signal and say i'm a good girl
and
you know everyone is beautiful blah blah
blah but if you don't measure up to
certain metrics that they want whether
a certain height a certain amount of
money a certain look
right look at women as kind of like
directors trying to cast an actor
if you don't fit that look that they're
going for they're going to immediately
disqualify you women are the selectors
guys there's a reason why being good
with women
is so uh coveted women reject most
men hell as a matter of fact most women
don't see 99
of guys they're invisible invisible okay
so you got to understand that women
are extremely ruthless when it comes to
mate selection
and that's gonna build upon the rest of
the stuff we're gonna talk about
right now i would agree like a lot of
girls have a lot of standards that they
like
have for the guys that they date number
four they use social media
and the internet in general well
especially social media right
uh to get opportunities and open doors
that you would never be able to do
as a man you want to talk about this one
first social media guy
so just so you guys know right if your
girls on social media
she's definitely on the market now she
may not want to be on the market
but just her being there and if she's
posting anything revealing pictures like
bikini pictures
her oh and about what i'm saying doing
her thing guys are going to comment
guys don't slide in her dms no matter
what trust me because we do it all the
time
but for the most part single married
fiance
it'll matter if she's there showing
herself off
she's going to get dms no matter what
okay i would agree if it's like just a
butt
picture although some girls do that for
work
not me not something i would do but i'm
just saying if like that's her job
and the second thing so a girl can't
have instagram
at all otherwise she's on the market if
she posts
anything or is it just the butt pictures
i would agree with the butt pictures but
like
what if she's posting you man story time
real quick guys
insert memory lane thing here roberto
the harp yeah how's that uh so other day
guys i was
going to the gym and i see this really
hot girl coming out of starbucks as you
guys know we're here in miami florida
beautiful women all over the place but
this girl was hot nice coke bottle shape
long black hair so i stopped her hey you
know my usual line you're almost cute as
me
what's your name blah blah we started
talking and you know at the end of the
conversation
i'm like hey so like what's your number
she's like oh i have a boyfriend i was
like okay no biggie
um are you on instagram yeah yeah right
so you put on your instagram funnel
which we teach you guys in dms on demand
which is closed right now but we'll open
it back up for you guys eventually
and uh i get her instagram and you could
tell a lot about a girl when you look at
her instagram
right so i got on her ig she only has a
few pictures of and
funny enough she told me i have a
boyfriend but there's no pictures with
her and the boyfriend
mind you this girl doesn't work she
lives in a very expensive building
and this guy clearly supports her
because when you look at her story she's
driving around on lambo trucks
mercedes trucks nice cars
where are these women i i don't have a
single friend
that has like a guy just paying for her
[ __ ]
i did not even know i was in a very nice
posh part of miami
so how was she affording this lifestyle
but do i not have hot friends
oh my god i thought my friends were hot
but
in like a totally straight way
i'm gonna just keep going never mind on
top of that when you look at her
pictures it's
all advertisement her in sexy dresses
looking hot
hair all down gym attire showing her
body off etc but no pictures
of her and her man today i look at the
story no cap
okay guys the guy has her name tattooed
on his wrist and she put that on her
story but when she flipped her wrist
she didn't have his name tattooed on her
it's a big up might you don't get a
tattoo before you get on her
instagram the symphony is real guys and
you have like a you know a nice watch on
and some bracelets so this guy has some
money
but he had this girl tatted on him guys
and she didn't have him tied on her
and she has no pictures of herself with
him but all her pictures
are sexy pictures of just herself guys
you know what i'll take a step further
with social media even if she does post
you
i got girls that got boyfriends in my
dms
so you're not safe either so either way
she's on social media
you're gonna you're gonna have some
trouble there boys guys
real talk if she's i feel like they're
describing a very
what i've learned is like a miami
lifestyle
i'm just a normal person man i'm just a
normal person
posting very scantily clad pictures of
herself
on the internet it's a dub man she's
advertising herself to the highest
bidder to the highest value guy
and if she doesn't put pictures of you
on there bro it's even
it's an even bigger l yeah dude so
anyway
if you guys are enjoying this video uh
we're midway guys
make sure to subscribe to us on anchor
where we
uh have our podcast don't tell me what
to do i'll do what i want
okay that's the fresh fit podcast behind
me and we release on spotify
apple podcast google every platform you
want to listen to it on
links are below click it subscribe
support the movement
we release five episodes a week every
morning three anchor exclusives
slash podcast exclusives audio only and
two video ones that we release on
youtube when we live stream or have a
guest in studio
so anyway back to regular schedule
programming number three
they have men in different positions for
different values
in their life jeffrey i like some tea
and some crumpets
and then tyrone blow my back out you
know what i'm saying like guys
think of women as like a head coach and
they have different players in different
positions okay
they got one guy at the point guard
position who's actually like doing the
smashing and dashing
then they got the center who's spending
all the money and the paint like going
hard in the paint getting beat up and
stuff like that
spending the money but not really
getting much of the reward and then she
got
other guys on the peripheral that are
supporting her with attention
maybe they can give her some utility
like one guy's a plumber
and fix his leaks or whatever well not
that kind of leak but you guys know that
or maybe that kind of leak who knows
where are i have never met like a girl
like this
for real like you know or he uh has some
kind of
benefit some way that he can benefit her
he has a nice car that she could borrow
like there are so many symptoms out
there that are willing to help a girl
out solely for existing
versus her actually earning that uh
benefit or treatment so guys
make sure that you're not the guy
getting used make sure when you're in
that situation
you're using her for what you want
because guess what she's going to take
full advantage if you let her
and you don't want to be the guy fixing
her fridge and then
larry from down the street gonna come
and plot her and be her real plumber
so whatever you do guys make sure you're
in the best position possible
and don't get used out here because they
will finesse you trust me they will
yeah bro if you ain't getting sex you're
gonna get wrecked don't be stupid all
right guys
don't let girls just use you number two
they keep you in the friend zone
for as long as they can so that they can
siphon off whatever resource you are
giving them
okay this builds on number three and i
gotta add to that too man yeah
you guys out here right trying to be her
friend first
to kind of ease in the back door bro
trust me you think that's gonna work
while you're doing that me and myron
gaines right here are gonna be at the
front door busting through like yo
what's good
come through to the crib stop i would
agree with that
once once you're
in the friend zone it's pretty hard to
get out of it
but i've seen people do it when i have
like
i've seen people do it doing the back
door stuff man if she wanted you to be
your friend
definitely she's gonna put you there for
a reason but not to smash
make sure that when you're talking to
the chick you'll let her know from what
you want
maybe not directly but indirectly so she
knows you're not trying to be your
friend
and that's it guys it's better to get
curved up front than be friends with a
girl and let her just use you for
attention or whatever utility you
provide
i can't tell you how many guys sit there
in the friend zone thinking oh my god
i'm just gonna you know let me just wait
a little bit longer and i'll get laid
let me tell you guys something i'm not
gonna count there are guys that make it
out the friend zone and eventually smash
the girl anomalies but let me tell you
something
you know when you're gonna get her when
she's older she's not as attractive
she's not as tight she might have had a
kid or two whoa you're gonna get her
yeah bro you're gonna get her when she's
at her worst she's gonna come back to
you when she can no longer
leverage her beauty to get resources and
attention from guys
you're not gonna get her at her best so
listen if the girl
wants to put you in the friend zone you
literally look her dead in the eye
ha no and you leave
they really see women as like
objects kind of like it seems like they
really only think their values through
their age and their beauty
so you guys think is that what the
internet thinks
oh my god i might as well die after 35
okay
because at least she's going to respect
you
for that a lot of you guys will sit
there and let a girl disrespect you and
put you in the friend zone
just so you can be around her respect
comes first when you deal with women
as a matter of fact it's more important
for her to respect you than to love you
and the problem is a lot of you guys
have it the other way around i want her
to love me and respect comes second
no bro she can claim to love you or have
love for you but she be cheating on you
meanwhile the guy she respects she would
never think twice to step out on him
guys
respect comes first number one the
number one dirty secret that girls do
not want you to know guys
is dremel please
they are dating a lot of dudes
at the same damn time yeah man listen
and and i already know what's gonna
happen there we're gonna have comments
for miles oh
you guys are misogynist oh how dare you
how dare you
i'm not talking to any guys any girl
that is halfway attractive
is talking to at least five to ten guys
smashing like three of them friends
owning like two of them having another
two pay a bill
and then just like it's casually texting
the other guys and that does not include
all the dudes that are hitting up on
your online dating apps text messages
whatsapp online dating sites sugar site
okay am i be nice guys
be nice don't don't you don't have to
get like super mean
but i just must not have been like hot
enough to get that level of attention
ten guys at the same time oh my god how
much free time do these women have
is that all they do for a living like
date
no it's whatever it may be man when
you're dealing with the most attractive
girls guys
they 100 are dating non-monogamously
with a lot of different guys think about
it she went to a buffet
and they gave you free food just for
showing up you don't have to pay nothing
it's all you can eat what would you do
you want to sit there and be like
oh no i'm not going to eat the sausage
because uh you know i'm going to exert a
little bit of discipline ah you'd be in
there eating a sausage man
these girls are doing the same thing
because you guys got to understand guys
are just throwing themselves at these
girls
thanks to the internet so for you to sit
there and say
oh she ain't getting down bro she's not
she's not meeting these guys or whatever
i know some girls that like were pretty
attractive and waited till they were
married
i'm just saying bro she's getting flown
out
it really depends on your values
like maybe in miami she's definitely
getting trips she's getting things paid
for
by high value guys in countries away
she's very good at disguising
her options because international trips
from guys who weren't even dating
what or like in a relationship with
because here's the thing i always say
guys woman's ability
to lock down a high-value guy is
contingent upon her ability
to sell you purity i'm a good girl
commit to me marry me you know what i'm
saying
because they know that guys innately are
repulsed by promiscuous girls
so girls that get around and travel to
meet men and do all these other things
most guys are going to look at that with
a little bit of i'll hook up with her
but i'm not going to take her serious
so girls do this as a survival tactic to
be able to lock down high value men
they can't tell you what they're doing
guys no chick is gonna sit there and
tell you
oh yeah i you know i i'm traveling you
know i go to california and see
hang out with this movie star i go to
miami and hang out with this football
player
i go to new york and play with this guy
from the hang out with this guy from the
knicks jean gonna tell you all that
she's just gonna tell you oh i haven't
dated anyone
in three years which is like code word
for
i've been smashing a lot of dudes you
know what i'm saying so guys
don't be stupid look guys i'm not mad at
females because they have a lot of
options
they have the ultimate abundance mindset
facts so that means that for example
they have a lot of options and trust me
any person with that much options
cannot fully choose the right option so
i'm never mad at them however
i will say this if you as a gay right
come to this being very naive
and not knowing what's happening she
said she's single to you
but she's single as a title but she's
talking multiple dudes at the same time
but that i mean before she even leaves
the house she's getting dms from guys
who want to fly out to
dubai france wherever just guys on
dating
france from people you don't even know
that's nice i'm saying hey
i'll do whatever you want if she's all
single or she says that to you
think about this she's single in her
head but in reality she's not so just
make sure whenever you need to check for
the first time just understand just hold
on to multiple dudes
try to become the one that she wants to
see right now yeah man
guys it's it's a it's a sausage buffet
if you guys know what i'm saying
for women and for us to sit here and say
oh they're not going to try out some of
the sausage
no they definitely are it's just the top
shelf sauce and don't get mad at it guys
it's just a part of game right yeah like
guys this isn't to like sit here and be
like
dude oh my gosh
i think this is a different world
that
like i went to college i know what that
world's like but like trips
10 got at the
anyways let me know in the comments if
you guys are from that world
and like you know what they're talking
about
let me know in the comments subscribe
subscribe
subscribe also if there's a weird like
noise in the background it's my dog she
snores
but i'll talk to you guys later bye